today is the end of week one day 5 is
down this class is very front loaded so
I think students feel it and I
definitely felt it yesterday yesterday
was probably the peak of just the
exhaustion of the class and getting used
to doing that in addition to my day job
I was frustrated because I wanted the
students to see what I was seeing and
they weren't and I felt like it was
because of an inability to clearly
articulate what I was trying to get them
to see today was so different we started
class with having them pitch the idea or
the point of their videos and there's
this nuance between an idea of a video
the point of the video and what a video
does and it wasn't until this morning
that I was I finally was able to
articulate in my head what was going on
with the students which was the
inability to distinguish a point from an
action so a lot of them were describing
what their videos did and using that
description as the point of the video
and I feel like we finally all made a
breakthrough today was when it sort of
became real to everyone because they got
to take their cameras and actually go
shoot stuff and it was just incredibly
gratifying to overhear them shoot and
hear them offer each other the same
pieces of advice I would and see them
take creative risks and experiment with
the equipment and to also see that they
really are a good class group like
they're just a really good group of
students i front loaded the class and
I'm realizing that it really was a lot
of work for them I wanted to equip the
students as best I could with the skills
that they needed to have so that the
rest of the month could be more about
them trying stuff on there on and I
don't know how I would restructure that
it's something that I have to think
about a lot and I thought about that a
lot coming into the class
but it was still a lot of work for them
this week in short today was excellent I
saw smiles on people's faces and I
witnessed them integrating things that
we had taught them this week